2,5 millionen views auf klicks um ihr im
monat wahnsinn aber dazu gleich mehr
auch wenn die szene aus dem ersten star
wars film schon 40 jahre alt ist
vielleicht kennst wie der ein oder
andere ein aufgezeichneter hilferuf von
prinzessin leia wird von r2d2 als
dreidimensionales video in den raum
projiziert seitdem tüfteln
forschungsteams weltweit daran genau das
in der realität wahr werden zu lassen
und tatsächlich es gibt erste wirklich
super spannende erfolge mal wieder ein
vorschlag von whatsapp und dazu jetzt
die allerwichtigsten facts zum thema in
klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen
zweieinhalb millionen views im monat was
für ein wahnsinn damit hätte ich
wirklich nicht gerechnet weil für den
wissenschafts kanal ist das absolut
rekordverdächtig tausend dank also an
alle die mich hier unterstützen
ich bin wirklich super happy und
besonders auf whatsapp da kommen ja echt
total coole themenvorschläge rein
einfach nur der hammer also allen hier
einen riesigen dank dafür dass er hier
so regelmäßig meine videos schaut
kommentiert bleibt und weiter verbreitet
ja vielen vielen vielen vielen dank und
deshalb habe ich zum schluss noch eine
kleine überraschung für euch ihr könnt
die realität verändern
wie das geht und zwar hier im video das
erkläre ich am ende es wird eben
auswirkungen auf die videos hier auf dem
kanal haben in jedem fall wird es lustig
ja die bislang entwickelten technologien
waren nur halb gelungen entweder waren
die 3d projektionen in der luft oder auf
plasma einfarbig oder sie hatten eine
minimale auflösung aber jetzt das ist
wirklich der wahnsinn
die jetzt entwickelte 3d projektion ist
hochauflösend schwebt frei im raum und
kann von allen seiten angeschaut werden
dazu daniel smith von der universität
unter wir nennen es auch scherzhaft
unser prinzessin leia projekt wir
wollten die 3d displays aus der science
fiction wirklichkeit werden lassen
wichtig hierbei es handelt sich nicht um
ein gewöhnliches hologramm sondern um
eine volumetrische projektion im
gegensatz zur hologramm haben solche
volumetrischen projektionen tatsächlich
drei dimensionen hier ist der
blickwinkel nicht eingeschränkt es ist
also tatsächlich möglich sich um das
volumetrische display zu bewegen und es
von allen seiten zu betrachten anders
bei einem programm das als
zweidimensionale projektionen lediglich
einen 3d effekt erzeugt winzige partikel
durch leser manipuliert machen das
möglich das ist ein wenig wie ein 3d
drucker völlig wir drucken gewissermaßen
ein frei im raum schweben das objekt mit
diesen partikeln das sagt molly die
partikel sind nur rund zehn mikrometer
klein und bilden so die pixel ein
unsichtbarer laserstrahl bewegt sie und
ordnet sie an sobald die anordnung passt
werden die partikel mit roten blauen und
grünem licht beleuchtet und zwar mit
hilfe von rgb
die so das sichtbare licht erzeugen auch
ein dreidimensionales video kann so
projiziert werden da der leser die
partikel bewegt bisher sind so schon
schmetterlinge leuchtenden ringe und
eine version der berühmten szene aus
star wars entstanden eine gestalt mit
bittend erhobenen armen leer hier statt
als prinzessin aber im laborkittel und
abgesehen von solchen spielereien können
sich die produktion auch hinsichtlich
ihrer auflösung sehen lassen 1600 dots
per inch das wurde so bislang noch nicht
erreicht ein anderes wirklich
nennenswerte das forschungsergebnis
wurde vor etwa drei jahren vorgestellt
ein forschungsteam aus japan hatte ein
holografische display entwickelt das 3d
bilder in der luft schweben lässt das
besondere hierbei diese bilder können
gefahrlos angefasst werden diese
entstehen auf eine andere art und weise
als prinzessin leia im laborkittel und
zwar mit hilfe eines lesers der
lichtimpulse abgibt diese haben eine
dauer im zweistelligen femtosekunden
bereich die lichtpulse ironisieren
moleküle am fokuspunkt zu einem plasma
dadurch geben diese luftmoleküle energie
ab in form von photonen also licht diese
lichtpunkte werden dann zu bildern
kombiniert noch sind die bilder recht
klein sie haben ein volumen von etwa
einem kubikzentimeter
doch weil die pulse so kurz sind können
sie problemlos angefasst werden das
tolle das display reagiert sogar auf
berührungen berührt man es mit dem
finger leuchtet das display heller zudem
spürt man einen kleinen impuls auf dem
finger da das plasma schockwellen
produziert ja dennoch völlig
ungefährlich für die haut so das
forschungsteam im gegensatz zur netzhaut
da ist ein schutz notwendig war na ja so
und jetzt hatte ich ja etwas versprochen
ich habe nämlich eine wette mit mir
selbst wenn ich diese unglaubliche zahl
erreiche zweieinhalb millionen views im
monat ist immer noch wirklich fahren
sind dann habe ich mir die haare in
einer verrückten farbe im moment bin ich
single da gibt's keinen ärger und jetzt
kommt es die ihr könnt die farbe
bestimmen heute abend mache ich eine
abstimmung auf whatsapp welche farbe
nicht nehmen sollen meldet euch also
hierbei whatsapp under könnte dann mit
bestimmt dann vater zudem vor allen
anderen
vom neuesten video vorab garantiert von
mir ihr könnt dort direkt in der
redaktion von pixum mitmachen und themen
vorschlagen und eben bei abstimmungen
der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das
aber mit der genau glocke vergessen und
hier geht es weiter dafür auch
draufklicken smarthome die zukunft des
lebens ansonsten würde ich mal sagen bis
dann bleib dran